let me see your hands let me see your
hands let me see your hands
newly released body camera video shows
what led up to an officer-involved
shooting in Idaho after the suspect
stabbed his father attempted to rob a
bank and ran toward police with a knife
in hand
let me see your heads dude
no yes get down here
get down it all started in Boise Idaho
on November 18 2022 when suspect Jeremy
waste stabbed his father his father was
taken to the hospital treated and later
released but waste went on the Run days
later on November 21st he attempted to
break into a locked Bank
and tell me exactly what's happened
um well we're not quite open yet we open
at nine and all of a sudden I felt
somebody like or heard somebody at the
front door
you know like pulling on the doors like
crazy and he had a black mask on and
then when he realized the door wasn't
open he beelined it over to a car which
I uh banned investigators say waste
drove off from the bank in a gray Honda
Odyssey later that day Ada County
Dispatch received an emergency call
reporting waste was trying to break into
someone's home the callers said the
suspect was driving that same minivan
hey well when the address of your
emergency
yes this is my Jeremy waste who has
wanted for stabbing his out in front of
my house trying to get it he just talked
back in his van
and this reason
he's wanted for stabbing who
stabbing his
please send someone out here there
should be people already out here
looking for him in the area
so he went down to the end of the Court
so what kind of vehicle did he get back
into it's a a gray Honda Odyssey Minivan
and I can't tell the plates he has but
he's coming in he's coming back in
coming back anywhere going back up
pardon me
please send someone else yeah I heard
he's right ma'am just so you know I
already have a call in for my officer so
if you could just let me know like if he
stays in his car or if he gets back out
of the car he's about to he's ringing
the doorbell again at my house
he's trying to get in actually at about
2 17 that afternoon investigators
attempted to Ping waste cell phone to
find his location but it didn't work
hours later at 4 45 he was seen at a
park riding a BMX bike by about 5 30
officers caught up with waste on the
bike path body camera video shows these
moments
thank you
hey he might have just ducked down if
somebody gets with me we can walk and
see me find him so there is
the clubhouse is gray and then to the
east there's an orange building that's
where he went between video shows an
officer running toward waste calling out
his location via radio
somebody get the Grand Forks he's on the
bike going eastbound
the officer calls for Waste to show his
hands but he refuses stop police
let me see your hands after that waste
rushes toward the officer armed with a
knife let me see your hands let me see
your hands let me see your hands
the officer continues calling for Waste
to show his hands but he still doesn't
stop it's then that a second officer
opens fire hitting waste
let me see your heads dude
yes get down here
get in after that officers put out a
shots fired call that's fired we're on
the bike path thank you let me see your
hands drop the knife throw it drop the
knife waste was later taken to the
hospital and treated for his injuries
after that he was booked into the Ada
County Jail while the incident happened
late last year the Boise Police
Department just released body camera
video and audio recordings this month
after the Ada County critical incident
task force completed its investigation
the Twin Falls prosecuting attorney
reviewed that investigation and
determined the officers acted
appropriately last month waste was
sentenced to up to 30 years in prison
for stabbing his father and rushing
toward police with that knife he'll be
eligible for parole in 10 years
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie